>>> NIGHT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, IT IS A DEBATE DIVIDING
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
AND REPUBLICANS LIKE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE BEEN
SEIZING ON THE ISSUE IN FINAL
CAMPAIGN PITCHES.
>> ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS WE
MUST DO IS STAND UP FOR PARENTS'
RIGHTS AND PARENTAL RIGHTS.
WE WILL GET CRITICAL RACE THAER
THEORY OUT OF OUR SCHOOLS.
EVERY PARENT IN AMERICA MUST BE
EMPOWERED TO OPT OUT OF FORCED
INDOCTRINATION IN THE ACROSS
ROOM.
>> Reporter: ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN CALIFORNIA LOSING HALF ITS
STUDENT TEACHERS OVER THIS VERY
ISSUE.
WAIT UNTIL YOU HEAR THIS STORY
FROM NATASHA CHEN OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: THERE WERE 84
TEACHERS IN THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT LAST YEAR.
THIS FALL THERE ARE 38.
IN LATE OCTOBER, CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY FULLERTON SAID
IT WILL PAUSE THE PLACEMENT OF
NEW STUDENT TEACHERS IN THIS
K-12 DISTRICT CITING LACK OF
CLARITY ABOUT TEACHING ETHNIC
AND CULTURAL DIFFERENCES AND THE
SCHOOL BOARD'S APRIL RESOLUTION
BANNING CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
>> ALL THOSE IN FAVOR.
>> AYE.
>> WHAT IS IT ABOUT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY?
>> LEE ANDRA BLADES IS ONE OF
THREE SCHOOL BOARD TRUSTEES WHO
VOTED IN FAVOR OF THE BAN.
THE TWO BOARD MEMBERS WHO VOTED
AGAINST IT ARE UP FOR
RE-ELECTION IN JUST DAYS AND
FACE FIERCE OPPOSITION FROM
CONSERVATIVE CANDIDATES.
THE TERM CRITICAL RACE THAER RI
REFERS TO A FRAMEWORK TAUGHT IN
COLLEGES, STATING THAT U.S.
SOCIAL INSTITUTIONS ARE ARE
LACED WITH RACISM IN THEIR LAWS,
REGULATIONS, AND PROCEDURES,
WHICH LEAD TO DIFFERENT OUTCOMES
BY RACE.
BUT CHT HAS BECOME A SHORTHAND
FOR CONSERVATIVE COMPLAINTS
ABOUT WAY THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES ARE PRESENTED IN K-12
CLASSROOMS.
SINCE JANUARY 2021, 42 STATES
HAVE TRIED TO EITHER BAN
CRITICAL RACE THEORY OR LIMIT
HOW TEACHERS CAN DISCUSS RACISM
AND SEXISM ACCORDING TO AN
EDUCATION WEEK ANALYSIS.
17 OF THOSE STATES HAVE IMPOSED
THESE BANS AND RESTRICTIONS
PROMPTING CONTENTIOUS DEBATE
COAST TO COAST.
>> IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY BE SYSTEMIC
RACISM, THEN THAT'S FINE, BUT
DON'T SAY THAT IT'S FACTUAL THAT
THERE IS SYSTEMIC RACISM IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THE IDEA THAT SYSTEMIC RACISM
IS NOT REAL SHOULDN'T BE UP FOR
DEBATE.
MY LITTLE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL KIDS
DESERVE TO LEARN THE TRUTH ABOUT
HISTORY AND THAT IS NOT GOING TO
BE ON THE TABLE.
>> Reporter: BOTH BLADES AND
BROOK HARPER SAY THEY MOVED TO
THE DISTRICT IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE GOOD SCHOOLS.
THE HIGH SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
RANKED AMONG THE TOP PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOLS IN AMERICA BY U.S. NEWS
AND WORLD REPORT AND OTHER
PUBLICATIONS.
THE DISTRICT HAS MORE THAN
24,000 STUDENTS, 70% OF WHOM ARE
NON-WHITE.
>> I HAVE FRIENDS WHO HAVE BEEN
HARASSED IN THE APARTMENT
AFTERSCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
ONE OF THE CROSS TOWN WHITE
SCHOOL, ONE OF THE SIGNS THAT
WAS MADE IS YOUR DAD IS MY
GARDNER.
>> THE SUPERINTENDENT TOLD CNN
IN THE STATEMENT THAT THE
PROCESS LEADING TO THE CRT BAN
WAS EXTREMELY CONTENTIOUS AND
DIVISIVE.
HE SAYS HIS SCHOOLS HAVE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO USE STATE
ADOPTED CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS.
>> UNDERSTANDING, EMPATHY,
COMPASSION, AND TEACHING THAT
WITH A LEVEL OF RESPECT FOR
GROUPS OF PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
THAT'S TEACHING UNDERSTANDING,
KINDNESS, AND RESPECT.
>> Reporter: RANDI SIMMS WAS A
STUDENT TEACHER AID 21 YEARS AGO
BEFORE SHE STARTED HER TEACHING
CAREER.
SHE SAYS LOSING MORE THAN HALF
THE STUDENT TEACHERS THIS YEAR
IS DETRIMENTAL.
IT'S A REAL WORLD IMPACT OF THE
CRT BAN, BUT BLADE SAYS THE
UNIVERSITY'S MOVE IS POLITICAL.
>> I AM REPUBLICAN AND I'M
CONSERVATIVE.
HOWEVER, I DON'T WANT MY
REPUBLICAN AND MY CONSERVATIVE
VALUES INTO THE CLASSROOM.
JUST PLEASE TEACH OUR KIDS.
>> YOU DON'T FEEL LIKE BANNING
CRT IS PART OF A REPUBLICAN
VALUE?
>> WELL, IT COULD BE.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S SOME DEMOCRATS
WHO DON'T BELIEVE CRT SHOULD BE
IN OUR SCHOOL AS WELL.
WE NEED TO JUST REMAUVE ALL THIS
NOISE.
THERE'S SO MUCH NICE IN THESE
CLASSROOMS RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: BUT HARPER HEARS A
DIFFERENT KIND OF NOISE.
SHE SAYS THE OPPONENTS OF CRT
HAVE CREATED AN ATMOSPHERE THAT
MAKES HER FEEL UNWELCOME.
>> I CAN'T GO ANYWHERE.
I DON'T HAVE THAT AS AN OPTION.
SO MY LAST QUESTION IS ALWAYS
WHAT IS THE END GAME?
>> Reporter: IN OUR INTERVIEW
WITH THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
LEANDRA BLADES WE TALKED ABOUT A
LOT MORE THAN CRITICAL RACE
THAER RI.
WE DISCUSSED THE ISSUE OF AN
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE, SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING, AND OTHER
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES PRESENTED
IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND BEHIND ALL OF THAT FOR HER
WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF THE ISSUE
OF PARENTAL RIGHTS, AND WE HAVE
SEEN THAT REFRAIN FROM OTHER
POLITICAL CANDIDATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THIS SEASO